obviously you are currently filming
stranger things four
and i'm just curious obviously he's a
huge fan of the series
and i know you can't say much but can
you sort of talk about
whatever the hell you can say and maybe
how this season compares to the previous
ones
i mean it's bigger that's uh the first
thing
in scope in scale even in the idea that
we're not in hawkins anymore
uh we locale wise are
we're bigger um and then in terms of
you know we're introducing new stuff
but we're also tightening and wrapping
up
in a certain direction to make it have
a clear clean specific and definite
ending at some
point which i can't really talk about
but um
and i i mean i can really only talk i
can talk about hopper
uh so far
it's i guess i say this about a lot of
seasons but it's
it's my favorite season in the sense
that he's at his purest he's at his most
vulnerable in a sense
i mean he's been as we've seen he's in
this russian prison
so we get to reinvent him in a sense i
mean he gets to have a rebirth
from what he had become and i've always
always sort of planned this
um this almost resurrection of like you
have
uh you have gandalf dies getting off the
gray and sort of re-emerge
and i i'm really interested in this
resurgence of him
we get to explore a lot of threads in
his life that have been
merely hinted at that will um
that we get to see a lot more of and
there's some real surprises that you
know nothing about
that will start to come out in this and
play big as the series goes on
um but it's really my favorite season i
just love it
all the scripts always get better and
these guys they started out the thing
season one is so tight and good and
intimate in a certain way it's so good
and these guys go in different
directions of which the fans have
multiple takes on but i will say
the writing continues to be of its
particular
specific genre whatever they're doing
each season
is just extraordinary and this again we
top it like i feel like it's a big
beautiful season i can't wait for people
to see it